So, in summary about generative models,
there are some good things about it,
right?
It's pure probability, right, very,
very clean probabilistic thing.
In fact, it's been known for a very
long time, which should give you a hint
that it's not going to be
the most powerful method used,
because it comes from a time when
computers were nonexistent or scarce.
And we had to use a lot of
mathematical reasoning,
pure mathematics in
order to do the work.
But it is, it says here,
firm probabilistic grounding.
It allows you to use your priors, so
if you have priors,
maybe your context gives you a prior.
I know I'm in a bedroom, so
the probability of seeing a lamp is
a lot higher than if I'm in a garage,
okay, that kind of thing, so
I can have a prior built into it.
One that's in yellow here, actually,
there's two of them that are yellow
because I think they
actually are important.
One is that because you're doing this
parametric modeling of continuous
functions, you can actually get away
with using a pretty small amount of data
compared to other methods we're going to
look at later, the discriminate methods.
So that's one, and
the second good thing about it is
your models are about each category,
and just about the category.
So when you tell me
about some new category,
I just have to learn a model for
that category.
I don't have to play with this model.
Whereas if I'm trying to learn how to
distinguish between an a and a b and
an a and a c, now you tell me about d's?
I have to worry about
a's versus d's as well.
So when you add in new categories,
and you're trying to discriminate,
you often have to worry about
a lot of different categories.
In the generative model, I just
build a model for that new category.
There are some other advantages of
generative models that we haven't
talked about.
You can use unlabeled
data in interesting ways.
You can also use it to generate data,
right?
So if I say something is
distributed over a Gaussian,
I can actually make more examples, and
there are times when that's useful.
So that would be all the good news.
What always follows the good
news is the not so good news.
So, where did you get those priors?
Okay, so again, do you go to Greece,
do you go to the Sears Prior Store?
The sensitivity to priors
really matters, and
the priors can be affected
by things like context.
There's this other thing
that's also kind of annoying.
I'm modeling skin and I've got not-skin.
Well, skin you might say
is a plausible model.
Not-skin?
Modeling not-skin is kind of
a weird thing, all right?
What I really want to do is model
sort of the, the boundary between all
the stuff that's skin and
everything else that's out there.
And by the way, a lot of the stuff
that's out there doesn't look anything
like skin at all, so that stuff is easy.
What I really need to worry about are
the things that are kind of like skin,
but aren't.
In fact, that's the next example.
It says, the example hard cases aren't
special, and they should be, right?
So I'm trying to recognize you know,
rattlesnakes in the brush.
I don't have to worry about
what Maseratis look like.
I do have to worry about the difference
between what rattlesnakes look like, and
maybe different kinds of grass, because
there's a tight similarity between them.
So this idea that modeling the hard
cases is really what's important.
And in fact, I think that's what's most
important about discriminative learning.
And then the last thing is, if you have
lots, and lots, and lots, and lots, and
lots of data, it doesn't really help.
If I'm modeling my world as a,
sort of a single distribution,
once I have enough data, doesn't really,
you know, I can fit some nice
mixture of Gaussians, I'm done.
It's not helping me comparing
against other elements.
So, it's not really
leveraging having large data.
So those are the downsides
of generative models.